hey what's up everybody I'm Tiffany
Smith for Fandango and we are here in
Bulgaria on the set of the follow-up to
the massively successful action-packed
film Olympus has fallen this is London
has fallen so we're gonna talk to the
cast and find out what's in store for
the follow-up it's my favorite part
right now because I worked a lot to skip
over a long time and you think up ideas
whole story points and you taken another
way our little moments and then you see
it come to fruition yeah actually good
pretty much shot in the face today what
by a blank it was a mistake somebody was
supposed to find out a dummy and when
they turned they still had an extra
bullet and they fired right past me last
like a punch in the face that kind of I
mean I have to say probably comes along
with the territory I'm doing a shell
action movie like this what is it about
doing them that you enjoy so much it is
incredibly intense hearing the guns go
off I mean we're standing over here and
I'm like I'm a little bit nervous the
explosions what's it like coming back to
this film and being with a lot of the
same actors in the same crew
what's comforting obviously you're
friends with them and you know Jerry &
Jerry's very much control it's his baby
and he cares very much about this movies
very passionate about it you're coming
in not only is the new guy but as the
villain the difference with this from
Olympus has fallen is that they've
gotten a little bit more into the
backstory of the villains or the
antagonists in my mind he's an antique
mm-hmm you know good villains never
think they're a villain yeah exactly
this one being called London has fallen
what monuments can we maybe expect to
see blown up for Rhett that's a secret
that come on you can't give me one eye
Melissa
the London Eye Big Ben Parliament either
I have had a great time here on the set
chatting with the cast it's gotten a
little bit chilly and rainy but that
hasn't taken away from any of the
excitement here over the past few days
and if it's any indication London has
fallen is going to be an exciting ride
[Music]
[Music]